und mir tut eigentlich die polizei
leitet die dann in solche situationen
kommt wie wir sie gerade vom wochenende
gesehen haben das will ja kein polizist
dass er sich da irgendwie in
handgreiflichkeiten wiederfindet mit
mitbürgern die entweder seltsame dinge
vertreten was sie dürfen oder aber
vielleicht einfach nur so rein geraten
sind und wütend sind dass sie ihre
meinung nicht sagen dürfen
das sind bilder die wir vermeiden muss
henry werden gesehen sie haben ab und zu
aber den ausführungen von claus strunz
auch mal gelegt wo hat er einen punkt
getroffen und wo ja war der punkt wo sie
sagen dass ich genauso da wird die
polizei von der schwere gesetz
vorgestellt vielleicht wollen sie aber
auch widersprechen auch das gerne eine
breite palette ich mache das sowohl als
auch also erstmal grundsätzlich sollten
wir uns darauf eingehen also wir glauben
an den rechtsstaat
ja und unsere kolleginnen und kollegen
das sollte man glaube ich man darstellen
die schützen das grundrecht auf
versammlungsfreiheit und nicht den
inhalt einer demonstration
natürlich ist auch in deutschland
polizeiarbeit gerade in der hauptstadt
immer ein stück weit politisch geprägt
ja ich meine wir haben gerade die
diskussion über grünanlagen und partys
in grünanlagen wo auch einsatzkräfte
immer wieder verletzt werden fragt es
seit über einem jahr kriegen es die
bezirk und der senat nicht auf die reihe
da für ordnung zu sorgen und dann wird
die polizei hat irgendwann dafür
eingesetzt also natürlich ist das immer
politisch geprägt ich muss ja sports
auch recht gibt natürlich gibt es auch
polizist und polizisten die das alles
nicht so toll finden aber alleine die
berliner polizei besteht aus 26.000
beschäftigten und wir denken nicht in
schubladen ja da kann auch jeder sich
sein teil dick ein bisschen probleme
habe ich mit der einschätzung ist immer
so schön wir haben ja auch 82 millionen
polizeiführer in unserem land
mittlerweile mit der einschätzung naja
ich hätte das lieber so laufen lassen
beziehungsweise ich hätte die
versammlung erst mal möglich und wäre
dann vorgegangen ich glaube wir haben im
letzten jahr sehr deutlich gesehen wie
schwierig das dann ist gegen
zehntausende vorzugehen
und auch beim csd sich spielen hier ja
immer wieder schön auch die bilder ein
beim csd es sind eben auch leute ohne
maske gelaufen völlig klar
beim csd sind aber auch viele mit maske
gelaufen habe ich gestern zum beispiel
eher weniger gesehen und ich habe aus
dem csd heraus auch wenn es am rand im
nachgang dann bei veranstaltungen auch
zu übergriffen und gewalt krank wird
dies keine legitimation gibt ist das aus
der masse heraus am anfang nicht
passiert das war gestern eine ganz
andere situation es gibt einfach die
erfahrungswerte uns genauso wenn ein
bekannter neonazi eine veranstaltung an
und bei seinen versammlung ist es in der
vergangenheit immer wieder zu
ausschreitungen gekommen
na ja da muss die versammlungsbehörde
das ja tun und ich möchte eine sache mal
ganz klar erklären
sie werden so was nie verändern können
und zu sagen na ja dann kann man bei
35.000 wenn denn dann verstöße sind kann
man gegen vorgehen also wir hatten
gestern ohne spaß wir hatten alles im
dienst was irgendwie nicht bei drei auf
dem baum war wir hatten
unterstützungseinheiten da ich kann
ihnen sagen ich habe mit kollegen abends
gesprochen die hatten schon 40 50
stunden in dieser woche und haben
gestern ich hatte einen der hat von 3 30
bis 22 uhr 15 bar im dienst und das
können sie durch fast alle
hundertschaften ruhig ziehen also wir
müssen hier auch mal darüber reden was
können wir eigentlich der polizei
zumuten ja wir haben ein eine
versammlungsfreiheit in unserem land wir
haben in berlin über 5000 veranstaltung
ist nicht immer der größenordnung aber
das sind diverse lagen oder muss man
ganz ehrlich sein das ist dann der der
ja vielleicht der fingerzeig in richtung
politik ja wo der unterricht dann muss
man dafür sorgen dass man mehr
polizisten haben ja wenn wir 50 60
tausend polizisten in berlin hätten und
nicht nur 26.000 ja dann hätte man
vielleicht diese versammlung auch nicht
untersagen müssen wir dann hätte man
vielleicht gegen die 35.000 querdenker
was auch immer vorgehen können was ich
aber eher stroms und das abschließen man
soll ja mal persönlich seien durchaus
auch recht geben und das habe ich anfang
der letzten woche bereits gesagt
natürlich ist nach dem csd der vorwurf
gekommen
die polizei wurde mit zweierlei maß
messen den muss man sich auch gefallen
lassen kann man argumentativ erklären so
wie ich es am anfang getan habe im sinne
wie die versammlungsbehörde so eine
entscheidung trifft und wie sie was
beantragt aber natürlich müssen wir das
kommunizieren und sauber kommunizieren
und genauso und das vielleicht als
letztes die haben selbst angesprochen
ist eine person gestern verstorben
natürlich gibt es jetzt auch welchen
social media ich sagen ja durch
polizeigewalt ist der mann verstorben
also sie können sich vorstellen dass die
kollegen draußen den hätte nichts
schlimmeres passieren können
jan mann der letztlichen herzinfarkt
bekommt bei einer polizeimaßnahme klar
da denken wir alle sofort an bord und
man muss sich sofort wieder sachen
gefallen lassen ist wichtig damit
transparent umzugehen
das wird auch untersucht ob es dann
zusammenhang mit der polizeilichen
maßnahme gibt oder nicht
es hilft jetzt den angehörigen nicht
weiter den ich erst mal mein beileid
ausrichten möchte aber ihre hände und
noch mal ganz kurz bei dem fall bleiben
sie sagen ganz genau alles auf den tisch
dazu denn tatsächlich koch das in den
sozialen medien natürlich jetzt schon
hoch und wird unter dem hashtag
polizeigewalt missbraucht dort dieser
fall
des todesopfers gestern auf dieser
demonstration deutet irgendetwas nach
ihrem jetzigen kenntnisstand darauf hin
dass dieser todesfall etwas mit dem
eingreifen der polizisten zu tun haben
könnte oder können sie das ausschließen
nach jetzigem kenntnisstand na ja wenn
ich ausschließen könnte dann würde es
die untersuchung nicht geben und die
türen nicht als gewerkschaft dadurch die
für die auch nicht die polizei durch es
ist so dass die berliner polizei da
gestern vom kenntnis bekommen hat dass
es einen vorfall gab es war auch ist
nicht an einer polizeimaßnahme passiert
das heißt dass jemand auf den boden
gedrückt wo er so soll das war eine
identitätsfeststellung ja das heißt ich
nehme jemanden raus der vielleicht keine
maske getragen hat der ist dann
vielleicht angespannt mit dem unterhalt
ich mich und dann ist nach unserer
kenntnis ist so gewesen dass der mann
über gesundheitliche probleme klagte
hatten krippen immer kalt schmeiß also
die typischen symptome dann haben die
einsatzkräfte vor ort sofort reagiert
hat die b gerufen erst maßnahmen
durchgeführt und die person ist dann auf
dem weg ins krankenhaus gestorben
wir sollten jetzt nicht vorverurteilen
das wort untersucht da kann man auch in
einem rechtsstaat wie deutschland sich
sicher sein dass das passiert ja und sie
können sich wie gesagt auch sicher sein
dass die berliner polizei das nicht
gerade toll findet was da passiert ist
weil natürlich dieser vorwurf jetzt nach
oben wird aber ich glaube sachlich das
zu analysieren wäre jetzt wichtiger an
ich kann nur versprechen dass wir nicht
unter den tisch gekehrt wird wenn es
irgendeinen zusammenhang gibt
sie sagt mir selbst hätte die polizei
die steht vor allem auch in berlin
derzeit oft unter druck es gibt einfach
zu wenige beamte im einsatz sein können
und es gibt auch diese bilder von der
nacht vom samstag auf sonntag denn dort
kam es auch zu randalen während einer
party nacht und dort wurden 19
polizeibeamte verletzt als sie
versuchten diese party aufzulösen und
mehrere hundert jugendliche hatten im
james simon park trotz chor ohne
einschränkungen gefeiert und getrunken
bis kurz vor 3 uhr hätten sich 2500
menschen in und um den park auf dann
rücken zunächst 30 einsatzkräfte ein
wurden von der menge mit flaschen und
steinwürfen attackiert und es soll auch
zu auseinandersetzungen mit messern und
macheten gekommen sein es gegen 6 uhr
morgens konnten die polizisten
den einsatz mit einem kräfteaufgebot von
etwa 100 beamten beenden
wenn sie diese bilder aus der nacht vom
samstag auf den sonntag sehen die
beamten immer einsetzen gerade gesagt
was muss sich ändern dass beamte so
attackiert denn mitmachten und messern
es ist ein ganz neues level der gewalt
gegen die polizei zunächst mal bin ich
stocksauer weil das eine frage der zeit
wann das auch mal so eskaliert der james
simon park ist seit über einem jahr
schon in den schlagzeilen weil es immer
wieder auch zu ansammlungen von jungen
leuten kommt die dort feiern wollen der
boot alkohol konsumiert werden drogen
konsumiert und unsere einsatzkräfte
kommen dann meist weil irgendeine
anwohner eine ruhestörung meldet und
gehen dann dagegen vor und werden mit
flaschen steinen begrüßt ich habe jetzt
keine kenntnis über markierten und
messer angriff auf unsere kolleginnen
und kollegen das war er so innerhalb
dieser jugendgruppen was auch immer aber
glas flaschen sind geflogen
dafür gibt's keine legitimation und ich
hoffe auch dass die verletzten kollegen
alle wieder schnell in den dienst
zurückkehren können sie haben es gerade
in den bildern sehr gut gesehen ist für
uns als gewerkschaft auch entscheiden
wir reden da ja nicht immer von den 100
schafften die man auch von versammlung
kennen sondern häufig sind des
abschnitts beamte die an diese erste
intervention machen sie sehen dass hier
auch mit teilweise mit mit polo shirts
nicht mit einer körper schutzausrüstung
und das ist es dann eben auch gefährlich
ich bin stocksauer weil wir seit
anderthalb jahren darüber sprechen es
gibt keine feier angebote für junge
leute und nochmals keine legitimation
für gewalt ja aber wir haben diese
problematik und senat und bezirk gab es
bisher verpasst irgendwie jetzt
möglichkeiten des feierns für junge
leute draußen zu ermöglichen wir reden
über strategien mit genesen geimpft was
auch immer man kann so was durchaus
organisiert machen oder man sitzt das
aus so wie es die politik seit mehr als
einem jahr macht und dann muss man ihm
maßnahmen ergreifen dass das uns
wohnparks nicht passiert der james simon
park ist relativ kleiner park ja man
kann keine pauschallösung finden für
alle parks dass man sagt man 2 und alles
ein
das gilt zum beispiel bei der hasenheide
über 50 hektar geht das nicht aber denn
simon park wendemöglichkeit
zugangskontrollen security
glasflaschenverbot alkoholverbote
wir haben eine menge sachen schon auf
den tisch gebracht ich kriege nur vom
kein bezirk politiker und auch vom senat
kriege ich nicht mit dass da irgendwas
passiert und unsere einsatzkräfte sind
dann die dies ausbauen können das geht
nicht
das heißt man sollte glaube ich darüber
nachdenken wie kriegen wir das vom tisch
ist immer in denen in den heißen
sommertagen und nächten so gewesen das
wird auch in zukunft zu passieren
wenn man sich nicht langsam mal überlegt
wie kann man dagegen vorgehen damit so
eine ansammlung gar nicht was passieren
damit unsere einsatzkräfte nicht in so
eine situation kommen da sind in erster
linie die bezirke und auch der senat in
der pflicht alternative angebote zu
schaffen und maßnahmen damit so etwas
nicht passiert keine unterstützung oder
zu wenig unterstützung aus der politik
das ist genau der punkt der intro wenn
wir über diese massiven angriffe gegen
ihre beamten sprechen die wir ja da eine
nacht gesehen haben aber eben ja auch
gestern auf dieser querdenker
demonstration hier in berlin brutale
angriffe auf ihre beamten selbst auf am
boden liegende polizisten und
polizistinnen noch das ist ein gewalt
phänomen dieser zeit aktuell und umso
wichtiger dieses gewalt phänomen zu
ergründen die berliner politik aber
scheint daran offenbar kein interesse zu
haben es gibt überhaupt keine statistik
dazu wieviel angriffe übergriffe es auf
ihre polizisten in den vergangenen
monaten in den vergangenen jahren gab
seit 2008 zehn werden diese daten hier
in berlin gar nicht mehr erhoben es
heißt wegen technischer umstellungen
harry jenter wegen technischer
umstellungen wird gar nicht mehr
die statistik erhoben wie viele angriffe
es auf ihre bahn
und wie sehr enttäuscht sie das verletzt
sie das er schildert den sie da einen
blinden es gibt diese zahlen natürlich
aber es ist eine fehlende wertschätzung
dass man das nicht statistisch auch so
wirklich auch schreiben kann müssen sie
gestern wurden auch wieder ganz viele
journalisten attackiert und ich hoffe
bei ihnen im haus summiert sich das dann
dahingehend auch dass man schon auch
cook wie viele von unseren kolleginnen
und kollegen werden eigentlich im
einsatz draußen für ihre arbeit verletzt
und genau das glaube ich diesen anspruch
durch polizisten polizisten es gibt
diese zahlen von angriffen ja natürlich
in der jährlichen polizei
kriminalitätsstatistik da sieht man über
7.000 angriffe da sieht man rund 2500
kolleginnen und kollegen verletzt
es gibt ja aber noch andere sachen die
erfasst werden müssen dienste unfälle ja
es gibt auch kolleginnen und kollegen
die kliniken auf der dienststelle wir
reden ja auch nur 1,2 millionen
sanierungsstau da kann man sich also
auch mal verletzen auf seiner
liegenschaft
es gibt kollegen die verletzten sich
anderweitig und das muss ich ja fassen
das hat auch was mit fürsorgepflicht zu
tun ja weil natürlich die behörde dann
auch maßnahmen ergreifen muss wenn ich
feststelle in friedrichshain kreuzberg
oder jubiläum james simon kjaer werden
verstärkt kollegen verletzt im einsatz
da muss ich irgendwann mal auch was
umstellen maßnahmen ergreifen damit das
nicht passiert wenn ich feststelle auf
einem abschnitt werden ganz ganz viele
leute immer wieder verletzt im dienst
auch selbst oder weil sie jemand
angegriffen werden
und ich habe da ein hohen
altersdurchschnitt da muss ich
vielleicht auch reagieren und vielleicht
ein paar jüngere leute rein nehmen also
was hat das mit fürsorgepflicht zu tun
und es ist so ein bisschen vogel strauß
mentalität das heißt ich steck mal schön
mein kopf entsandt und dann ist das
problem weg das ist natürlich mitnichten
und was nicht vor allem ärgert wir reden
über eine statistische erfassung mehr
fassen heute alles ja wie viele
kaninchen boden gefunden was auch immer
und im jahr 2021 sollte es möglich sein
mit dem knopfdruck das zu drücken und
diese daten liegen vor es gibt für jeden
dienst noch für einen dienstunfall
anzeige in der berliner polizei die muss
es geben weil da natürlich
beamtenrechtliche folgen auch mit
krankengeld dranhängen von daher muss
ist diese zahl geben und ich erwarte
hier dass man wir haben das letzte woche
auch schon gesagt ich erwarte mir dass
man das technisch lösen kann aus
fürsorgepflicht auch und salz zeichen
der wertschätzung und wenn man das nicht
hinbekommt dann sollte man jemanden
einstellen der das handy aussieht